[camera flash]
[applause]
Dior:
People need to feel again.
They need to dream again.
Dior:
They need to live again.
We can create a new world for them.
This is a story about Christian Dior
creating The New Look during World
War Two.
Ben Mendelsohn:
He brought back fantasy and elegance
in a difficult time for Paris.
Todd A. Kessler:
The New Look was the name of Dior's
iconic first collection in 1947.
It symbolized healing
and brought a nation back on its feet.
Juliette Binoche:
To understand fashion today,
you've got to understand The New Look.
It's a time of great talent.
John Malkovich:
Dior, Chanel, Balmain, Balenciaga,
Givenchy, Pierre Cardin.
Todd A. Kessler:
Dior was a young designer, but Coco Chanel
was the grande dame of fashion and was a worldwide celebrity.
I explore the dark layers of her life.
Juliette Binoche:
Humanity is complex.
Life is not all black and white.
Have you ever thought about
Chanel:
what a woman has to face to survive in this world?
You men and your wars, your rules.
Todd A. Kessler:
These icons were forced to make challenging decisions
during World War Two.
Ben Mendelsohn:
Dior's sister, Catherine, is a resistance fighter.
Maisie Williams:
We feel we know so much about these figures.
But this story really dared to explore
the sides that we had not really considered before.
This is a story of survival and resilience.
[laughs]
Fashion needs a great collection to rise
from the ashes of the last five years.
Creation is our survival, our salvation.
We can interpret the pain
Maisie Williams:
in the world through creativity.
We have the capacity
as human beings to transform.
And that spark is a beautiful spark.
Catherine Dior:
It's time to show the world what you've created.